this whole
idea is complete genius the artistry is
absolutely beautiful and this lineup of
music artists would make one of the best
concerts ever
so thank you as you can see i'm a music
fan
by the vegas posters on my wall so i'm
curious chris for you how did this
come about i mean did you just have a
light bulb moment one day where you
thought i'm going to put together this
incredible group of artists to write
songs about
civics that we're going to animate i
mean how does that even happen
you know i i've spent my career uh
trying to work during the day on the
things that bother me at night and keep
me up and keep me uh
awake and the last few years have been
really
intense um and and i'm someone who has
always followed politics and
and loved the the idea of governance and
i i felt like we had lost a common
language
of how to think about our country how to
feel like
americans outside of any political split
um and i i i had moved to netflix
and they were saying what do you want to
do and i was like i want to do
this uh and at the same time the obamas
had moved
to netflix kenya barris was at netflix
and so
we we joined forces to bring this
project together
um and once you have the obamas on board
you get to dream
the your dream uh scenario and these ten
um uh animators and these ten musical
artists were exactly that
her for you i mean what is that like
when you get approached for the project
like this i mean it seems like a
no-brainer you want to do something
that's
netflix and the obamas but then you find
yourself
having to write a song about a subject
like this so how does that
work well i mean i enjoy those those
kinds of challenges you know writing a
song with it with
a purpose with an intent to educate or
start a movement or start a change or
something like that
like i that's in line with what i want
to do anyways in my own music so
when i heard about the project i was
like of course i want to be part of this
and i felt like
you know this is like perfect you know
and so um
i just thought it was so special you
know one of the goals is always
of course to inspire especially young
girls but
um to inspire all people and empower all
people and what better way to do it than
with a project like this
on on a great platform that we watch
every day anyways you know
um so i thought this would be this would
be a really really great project
what was your process for writing this
song is it something that you did
quickly or does it
slow everything down when you know that
you have to do this project
and you hope that you know the obamas
are happy with it when you're done right
it took it took a bit of time i mean
i was doing so many other things and
this required you know so much focus and
making sure the facts were right and
making sure everything was correct so
um what i really wanted to do was like
make sure i was in the right like
mindset you know to write about this and
get excited about it
and and i really wanted to make a uh
like a feel-good song you know like
when you hear something uh about active
citizenship it should make you want to
get up and do something whether it's get
up and dance or whatever so
um i kind of thought about that like it
should be a little upbeat have a little
bit of a groove to it and
um yeah i started to think about all of
these things to that it means to be
an active citizen all those things and i
realized
that there were things that i i kind of
already knew you know but i just forgot
that that's really what it means to be
an active citizen you hear that word and
you know kids probably get intimidated
but it's daily things it's it's things
that we
um we think are are small but really
contribute to big change so
that's what i thought about and thinking
about that hook you know we've all felt
like
we're we don't matter our voices don't
matter or you know
we're just one person or i'm too young
or i come from this background or i'm
i'm this i i can't do anything
this song is really letting people know
you have a voice and it does matter
i will i'm just gonna jump in and say
when that song came in
it it we all knew we were suddenly
sitting on something that was like
clicking on a different level
um and and it was one of the first songs
that we heard back from president
obama that he had heard it and that he
was so
incredibly moved by it we also used it
as bait to get peter on board
and it worked yeah i mean peter you you
obviously know what you're doing when it
comes to animated projects that push
boundaries but
what were the unique challenges with
something like this to take this song to
have your own animation style to do it
all in three minutes
seems crazy yeah you know but it it
i mean i've i've said it before i'll say
it again the the song made it easy
you know honestly the the storytelling
and the vibe of the song were so
complete
you know her her got the assignment
so perfectly that uh
it was just drawing on what she had
already
created in the song i mean just the you
know the the lyric that she referenced
if i'm just one person
you know does my voice even stand out
that alone kind of tells you oh this is
the story of
one young woman who's you know
a little intimidated but is gonna become
brave enough to speak up and make a
change
and there were other images you know
drawn from the lyrics
uh that you know the the city council
meeting a
letter to the mayor uh planting a tree
and recycling
that idea became like the spine of the
whole thing so
it was all there you know and and the uh
the visual style and the uh the rhythm
of what we wanted to do in terms of our
our images our transitions our colors
all of that came out of the vibe of the
song
so it was really uh you just had to be
open to what was already there
so you know so completely and and go
with it
and and uh yeah that
that really was the blueprint and it was
it was easy
yeah i mean those lyrics really struck
me too it made me immediately remember a
friend that i had
in high school who told me you know i'm
not gonna i don't
vote i'm not gonna do that because it
doesn't affect me
i'm you know this isn't gonna do
anything in my life and
now i can refer people like that to this
song so yeah i mean you know you get
you get 30 million people saying the
same thing
and yeah of course nothing's gonna
happen you know but if you have
you know one person like you know one
hopefully
knock on wood one person hears this song
and goes hey wait a minute
and gets inspired just to speak up a
little bit and
touch all these other people when you
look at
past work like schoolhouse rock and and
even like hamilton
is the trick then to getting people to
learn something that might
seem dry or boring or uninteresting
just making it really cool i think so
yes it's just why we got her on this
project
i'm not going to make anything cool
we're going to make it cool
yeah i think i think it's things that we
should already know um
and and the problem is working against
the way that
some things have been presented at some
point you know sometimes it's
the way at which it's been presented
before can discourage us
from thinking that you know it's
important so it's really just bringing
the focus back on like hey
it's this it may not be simple but it's
this
it's this important and it's and it's
it's really daily things and it's things
that do matter and um
yeah when you have a good beat to that
then of course you know
like it's yeah of course you hear it and
you're
kind of learning on accident in a way
you're learning on accident because you
love the song and you're digesting that
song and sometimes
when you're taking in a message you
don't realize that you know
you're getting out that message that you
start you start thinking
differently you start moving differently
because of what you heard because of
how much it affected you one of my i was
just gonna say one of my biggest fears
right now
in this moment in our country both
politically
after uh you know coveted after george
floyd
after everything that is going on is
that it's going to make
kids sad depressed and lean
and lean back right and to feel
powerless and
all i think all of us feel this sense
that actually
we have a bright future if if our youth
get involved
and we're just trying to say you we we
are the people you are the people go
take your power
and and and change what you don't like
in this country it doesn't matter what
it is it's not political
civics is about you have the power to
get your opinion
moved through this country and change
the direction we're going in
was it like for you to go from this idea
to
then having this incredible lineup of
musical artists
and this beautiful visual animation to
accompany it
and to see all those finished products
uh
well i i i've mentioned i tend to cry a
lot i'm pretty emotional
um and there have been quite a few
moments on this project where where
that's been the case but uh
look for me it's selfish i don't i don't
know how to get up in the morning
and and and and attack my day and
feel positive if i'm not um actually
using the work that i do
uh to affect change so the fact that so
many incredible
people joined me in that process i hope
they too
are taking in the selfish part of it um
being involved
is both a selfless and selfish act you
will feel better
if you um if you if you take some power
and go out there and
be bold and uh you know this is a world
of like
i asked i asked kenya i asked the
president the first lady
we asked all these artists and uh if
you're if you're on point people will
join you
did you ever get nervous or worried
along the way that somebody wouldn't be
able to deliver
yes oh my goodness all the time um and
yet
every single one of these songs is
amazing i mean i was worried about
we were asking for a lot of content in
some of these and that's it it
just inherently was a lot to ask hey can
you make a radio play song about
fed versus state or taxes um we knew is
a big ask but
everybody stepped up they're the songs
are amazing
i'm such a big music fan that there are
albums in my life
that i remember my life before i heard
that album in my life after i heard that
album
and it there's been some conversation
today about you know how
songwriting is sort of a musical artist
superpower
so i'm curious for her i mean because
that is something that is so elusive
it's hard to explain to people how you
write a song
does it feel like a superpower it does
it does because it's like a given for
most songwriters it's not something that
you've had to think about too much you
know you kind of just do it it's really
a gift
it's a gift and it's it's like if you
use your
your gift and your superpower for good
then you're a superhero
you know and um that i think that's the
beautiful thing is when you can do
something that you love
and it just so happens that it changes
people's lives or just so happens that
it teaches people
um or you know makes people feel good
and uh
yeah kind of yeah kind of does feel like
a superpower
peter for you i mean you've done
animated features
doing something like this that is only
three minutes
did it change how you view animation is
it gonna affect how you do
animated features going forward
hmm interesting um you're going to hand
in a five minute feature and be like i'm
done
done i don't know if it i don't know if
it
changes anything about that i mean it it
made me want to do more short pieces
you know i my my whole career has been
in features so
you know weirdly enough you know the the
idea of doing shorts was a little like
wow i'm
i don't know if i can you know is that
i'm
that's man that's not much time but uh
once again i have to keep going back i
have to keep going back to the song i
mean
it was it was so much all there you know
i mean i was going back and forth with
chris for a long time about
whether i can oh i don't know if i'm
going to have enough time to do it and i
had this that blah blah blah and um
i'm telling you as soon as i heard the
song i mean the ideas just started to
download right away and i was like oh
okay i guess this is gonna work and uh
yeah
luckily for for me i i think i think it
i think it worked uh i think it worked
pretty well so
yeah i mean i guess the thing i learned
was just say yes more often
probably i'm gonna call you in about 10
minutes with my next ask peter while
you're in that mood
yeah i mean for her what was it like to
see the visual with
your music i mean seeing that for you
all put together
did it feel like it came out of your
head or were you surprised to see
it brought to life in that way oh man i
haven't even got to tell people how
excited and how amazing that it turned
out like
the details and the diversity and like
he said like kind of starting off
with not necessarily being sad but more
melancholy kind of like
okay what can i make of this world you
know colors and then going into this
vibrant world
and like you said the planting seeds
with the trees and the the
the guy with the boombox is probably my
favorite part just because
it just it shows that's literally a
visual representation of a call to
action and how fun that can be and how
important it is and how we do it anyways
but this is another level of doing it
and
um yeah i literally brought the lyrics
to life it was like really cool to see
i'm like oh my gosh
this is like a whole like you know it
really made it special because
i know we all kind of went into it with
this passion so when you see it come to
life
it turns out to be more than anything
you expect because you know it's the
special thing and i know
for chris has been a really like thing
that's been close to her so
you know i was just so proud to be a
part of it because of her passion and
to see it brought to life is like wow
like this could be something that
is in the classrooms and in people's
homes for so many years and it will be
for so many years to come um and that's
that's very exciting
yeah i mean how does it feel to be able
to make social and political change
through
your music between i can't breathe and
your song for judas and the black
messiah
leading to an oscar i mean like what
does that feel like
it's overwhelming in a really good way
you know initially it's like
oh wow you know somebody told me one of
my songs their their 70 year old jewish
father
called them and was like have you heard
this song by this girl it made me think
differently and at that moment i was
like oh
wow that's crazy like something that i
wrote
is making you know somebody think
differently and and that's how you
change the world it's so small those
little things and
um i i can't i can't believe that you
know
just me you know i'm doing something
like that it's very very very special
but it also makes it reminds me like
okay just keep doing what you're doing
and um
you know don't don't feel like okay i
have to do this i have to do this it's
like
i'm doing exactly what i meant to be
doing and in a way that
um is just so personal to me that's why
it's affecting people because it's
it's something that i feel it's coming
from me it's not coming from like
oh because i have a bunch of followers i
have to speak out on this
when we think that way we only move when
we feel an obligation to and
not because we want to and i think
that's one of the biggest things
especially with a project like this like
oh i think we need to have this like why
don't we
want to like there would be so much more
change if we felt like
more compassion you know more compassion
towards people more compassion towards
making a change and and looking at the
world and actually asking those
questions to ourselves and not waiting
for the next person to do it because
they feel an obligation to so yeah you
know it's bigger than a responsibility
it's it's
um it should be the way that that it is
well for all of you please keep doing
what you're doing because this was
awesome
and i appreciate you talking to me about
it thank you so much
thank you thank you